früher oder später erleben
Moment
sondern redet darüber mit das Paar Tipps
aus der Philosophie
[Musik]
heute zeigen
wir den später
und das gemacht haben
wenn sie toxische Beziehung ist dann ist
per SMS Schluss machen für dich sogar
machen
oder verbale
kommunizieren stimmt für mich
an Sprachnachrichten
reagiert irrational und es kann mit
Vorwürfe ich finde es andere eigentlich
wenn man es einfach mal so kommuniziert
und los setzen und noch eine bitslebener
nüchternen
diskussionsangeht
das Ersetzen miteinander reden
irgendwie auseinandersetzen aber ich
glaube wer wirklich liebt der geht sich
drinnen mit Hund und Haar macht sich
verletzlich und mit dem ich völlig klar
dass natürlich empfindlich ist das der
andere Gott ich finde so ganz insgesamt
ist es ja sowieso ausgegangen dass
Phänomen vom Ghosting wo liegt einfach
verschwindet zum Leben
Energie also je unverbindlichere
Beziehung umso mehr ist natürlich als
SMS oder das sogenannte Ghosting okay
wenn es aber wirklich jahrelange
Beziehung
zum Beispiel oder vielleicht auch
nochmal die Chance überzogen
und vielleicht gibt es so einen
Unverbindlichkeit zumindest schreibt man
das ab und zu oder es geht ja natürlich
Anonymität
kann irgendwie noch bringen du bist
einfach immer wieder
im globalendorf oder der Stadt oder im
Netz ich habe einfach Problem
wenn sie natürlich wie es Probleme haben
die sind einfach in der Beziehung wo sie
sich schon lange im wohlfühlt getrauen
ich finde es extrem problematisch bleibt
aber das
machen
problematisch weil du weißt schon was
passiert bis ernsthaft und so vielleicht
ist gar nicht gegangen so das weiß alles
nicht das natürlich krass passiert
ein bisschen nicht erreicht und ich habe
wirklich Angst gehabt bis ich gemerkt
habe
ja ich meine im Nachhinein
ich finde im Nachhinein
Tagebücher
ist das generell bis dass man verlieren
sich richtig trennen also Aldi die die
Tugenden Antarktis lecker
warum die Liebe weh tut dass man hört in
erster Linie negative Beziehung mit dem
meint sie so One Night Stands friendship
plus Aldi verschiedene Formen so schnell
sind so kurz
miteinander und dann nicht mehr
irgendwie ja gar nicht richtig trennen
will man aber gar nichts das finde ich
konservative gesellschaftskritikpunkt
und und offene Beziehungen und so weiter
Freundschaft plus das sind modal neben
der anderen ab der zweite Kiste und ich
finde man muss es nicht abwarten und
sage dir reicht das Ideal nicht vor dem
lang bis das Ende vom Leben ich finde
das ist vor glaub dass mir das Schema
immer noch im Kopf und sage das ist ja
das muss sie und alles andere
erreicht das nicht gibt völlig recht ich
glaube was ich aber nicht nur je nachdem
was für ein Typus bezieht du hast
natürlich ganz andere Sachen gefragt
[Gelächter]
Meinung und es ist so dass sie den
später darüber geschrieben hat wie das
eben das so gut und alles wunderschön
sich einfügt dass jetzt ihre Ex-Mann mit
Hund wenn sie mit ihrem neuen mal sehr
gut
die andere Beziehung
vielleicht ist das neue Liebe dass man
irgendwie den mit dem Schlag und und
alle mit allen und alles schön
miteinander
Emotionen gegen die stationiert sondern
da passiert der mega viel lass dich
einfach die Person irgendwie jeder Mitte
zieht einfach hassen was du vorhöflich
am Anfang
erklären oder was immer gemacht passiert
ich finde ein bisschen
Bayer wo sie unter anderem sie
aufgeschrieben hat immer eine Aufsatz
der heißt Trust also wie ihr
vertrautenfreundinnen und die Gott darum
dass man die so in Beziehungen immer
extrem verletzlich machen das ist
wirklich Kehrseite
ohne die Verletzlichkeit und das
ermöglicht dir natürlich auch über das
Handy für die Beziehung aber vor allem
auch im Trainingsprozess im Gegenüber
extrem witzig machen wie Du genau die
Wunder genau weißt setzen und das nicht
machen sondern eben gesehen
das Vertrauen oder gegenüber geschenkt
hat dass du mit dem Muschi ganz
vorsichtig umgekehrt extrem wichtig ist
zum Beispiel interessant dass sie die
Literatur ganz oft Freunde oder
Freundinnen der Verrat begannt zum
Beispiel Bekannte judaskus oder wer
verratete Jesus hat Römer der Judas und
natürlich weiß wurde
und das glaube ich ist wirklich bis zum
normal gut verstehen mit dem Vertrauen
in Expartner und mit dem Taschentücher
sehr viel verletzen und und deswegen ist
super interessanter Punkt
interessant
eigentlich nur in liebesbezüge trennt
den Freundschaften hat
sich einfach auseinander ja aber das
geht natürlich ein Bezirke oder also
Freundschaften schlafen
also wenn man geschafft ja also wenn man
einfach nur unter einem Dach der Wohnung
aber eigentlich ist mir nicht ich glaube
das gibt's aber Freundschaften musst du
immer machen
extrem oder sehr wenig
sprechen
Schweiz
ich finde die Idee dahinter ähm
Interviews geht von der Seite okay
Moment einfach
selber mit anderen um im Münchner
palter werden egal was passiert ich
glaube das ist immer noch tabu also
Training ist irgendwie schmerzhaft das
ist anstrengend vor allem ein kindisch
und so weiter oder du musst auch
finanzielles schwieriger
stelle ich mich mega wichtig das stimmt
ich interessant früher immer so
Objektive Training gehen wie zum
Beispiel
ganz schlimme Sachen schweren
Alkoholiker oder
anderen finanzielle Ruin oder so während
der Filme emotionale Grund und was sie
schön findet
im sinnvoll du darfst
höchstens sprechen
[Musik]
Etikett dadurch Schrecken und wenn man
dann immer den
kann man sich natürlich
Freiheit drin also dass man nicht immer
nur quasi auf abrufen bleibt und immer
nur so
vorübergehend sondern
mega schön
Multi optionsgesellschaften muss negativ
und nicht erschafft und so aber ich
finde immer so gut aber wenn man dann
irgendwie egal läuft
extrem weh und über das reden wir jetzt
noch was macht man eigentlich wenn man
Liebeskummer hat am Handy
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
erfolgreicher Podcast das bezirkskosmos
und Episode gemacht und Dieter Punkt
ganz wichtig finde weil sie das Anbauen
mega wichtig ist ist Akzeptanz und das
war wirklich
die Person nur zurück bleiben ist immer
noch hat noch Jahre und irgendwie auch
nicht darüber hinweg doch immer noch das
Gefühl ich hasse nicht wirklich
akzeptiere ich hoffe immer noch es ist
schon Form von Truhe los du verlier aus
dem labern Teil für den Identität oder
der Vergleich mit der Truhe mit dem
Verlieren mit dem Sterben mit dem Tod
die Thema aus Ritual oder von der
katholischen Kirche
beerdigungs-
oder also du bist schwieriger
[Musik]
Frage ist das eigentlich wirklich so
komische sinnvoll wirklich also
scheidungsritual oder trainingsritual
produzieren
überhaupt nicht auf die folgende Klasse
Adresse
kaputt ich finde interessant zu
unterscheiden sind Rituale macht oder
vielleicht
es geht jetzt ganz bekannte Beispiel
machen und so
aber grundsätzlich ich weiß nicht ich
finde jetzt
sagen über 100
links vom Anfang
machen
Tablette extrem poetisch schön
oder sowas
[Gelächter]
[Musik]